our YouTube channel got taken over by
hackers maybe you didn't see but this
account Tesla official hacked into our
account even though we had two-factor
authentication on and a really hard to
crack password and they privated all the
videos luckily it didn't delete them
took the cover off changed everything
but thank God we got it back and so if
you're fired up that the think media
podcast channel is back hit the thumbs
up button drop some love in the comments
and I want to just ask you one I
appreciate you sticking with us here and
two we are now putting all the videos
public again we fixed our we put our
Avatar back we're getting the Channel
all back again but the traffic on the
channel completely flatlined and so it
would mean the world to me if you maybe
head to some of your favorite episodes
in our library show some love and the
likes drop some love in the comments
because we lost some momentum because of
a couple weeks of the hackers taking the
channel down grateful that YouTube and
Google were able to to get us back in
and here we are the future is bright for
the think media podcast and make sure
you're subscribed because we're going to
be releasing some episodes about this a
lot of friends in the YouTube and cyber
security World reach out to me on
Twitter sharing about how hackers are
doing this how sophisticated hackers are
getting and so we're going to be
bringing on some guest interviews to the
think media podcast to share their
wisdom so you could protect yourself and
so we could take our cyber security to a
whole nother level and so I appreciate
you think media podcast in fact if you
haven't seen these recent episodes we're
going to be catching up click or tap the
screen to check out this video that I
know you're gonna love from this series
and shows here my name is Sean Cannell
for just meeting rhymes with YouTube
channel appreciates you and uh we're
back y'all talk soon